RETO MEIER: Hello, my
name is Reto Meier.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And I'm
Ian Ni-Lewis.
RETO MEIER: We're kicking off
2013 by launching our pure
Android collection here on a
very special episode of--
IAN NI-LEWIS: The App Clinic.
RETO MEIER: It's been awhile
since our last App Clinic but
we've been hard at work during
the interval testing your apps
in some pretty remote and
extreme conditions.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That was a tough
one for you, I remember.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, I struggled.
But the things I do for this
team and for this job.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
I simply stayed here and poured
beer on my phone.
We have to do stress-testing.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
We all do what we can.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well anyway, we're
back now and we're ready
to get back to work.
RETO MEIER: We thought the best
way to get back into the
swing of things was to remind
everyone what the App Clinic
is all about.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And what better
way to do that than by showing
off some of our graduates.
And officially launching--
RETO MEIER: Pure Android.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Pure Android is a
Google Play collection that
we, along with Roman, Nick, and
Adam from Android Design
in Action will be curating.
You can find it at bitly dot--
er, bit.ly is that--?
Do we just say bitly?
RETO MEIER: Yeah, I'll
just go with bitly.
I think we just say bitly.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
bit.ly/PureAndroid.
RETO MEIER: Yeah.
It's a way for us to shine some
light on the Android apps
that we've examined
during be App
Clinic, often quite candidly.
But they've really built
something beautiful and
intuitive, and taken some
feedback that we've given to
create something which
we really like.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
It's also a small way of saying
thank you all the
developers who submit their
apps to our constructive
criticism, and who then turn
around and make their apps
even better.
RETO MEIER: And so we're
going to be adding
to this list slowly.
So there's only a couple
of apps that
we'll be adding today.
And we're going to hope to try
and find a couple of really
good examples, maybe every week,
maybe every other week.
So it's a list that
we hope to grow.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh yeah,
I've got a list.
RETO MEIER: There's lots of
great apps out there, but we
want to make sure we give each
app the opportunity to really
shine by itself first.
So that's why we're going
to go slowly.
And every time we do induct
someone in our hall of fame,
we're going to do it live on the
App Clinic, so stay tuned
for the end of the show when
we're going to give you a
little more details on what it
takes for you to create an app
worthy of the Pure
Android title.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
So today we're inducting two
apps into Pure Android, both
of which we looked at in the
very early days of Android
Developers Live.
RETO MEIER: And that's Pattrn
by Lucas Rocha and Tasks by
Team Tasks.
And it's not just because
they're both using Apps Clinic
as their color palette.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Although, that
does tend to make, you know--
yeah.
RETO MEIER: It's not
going against them,
I'll say that much.
IAN NI-LEWIS: No, no.
Let's start by taking
a look at Pattrn.
RETO MEIER: All right.
So right off the bat, you can
see that they've done a great
job on a Google Play
feature page.
The branding is really
striking.
And it's still entirely
consistent between their logo
and their feature graphic.
And you can see how this
banner is really
going to stand out.
No matter what size it is, if it
does get featured in Google
Play, you're going to
notice this banner.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
And you can tell it's not just
that they've made something
big and bold.
They've also taken a lot
of care with the pixels
themselves.
They do have a little bit of
drop shadow, but it's not
obvious, just to
separate them--
the pattern from
the background.
They've done some design.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
And that's really important
for the sort of
app that this is.
Something which is visual, which
people who care about
designing would be
interested in.
It really pays to take
that extra step and
make that extra effort.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
It also gives you a grade
A idea of what the
apps going to do.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
So throughout the
app, the design
language is really clean.
It's really uncluttered.
It's intuitive and it's entirely
consistent with the
Android Design Guide.
And you can see that as you move
through the app you're
never left wondering where you
are, what you should be doing.
The navigation is obvious.
The screen design
is really clear.
There's not extra stuff
going on there.
They've tried to keep it as
visual as possible and as
non-intrusive as they can.
And if you look at their tablet
layouts-- which is sort
of key as well to being
pure Android.
You can see that they've
implemented a fantastic
responsive design that
works well both in
portrait and in landscape.
And that's really important and
really exciting for me to
see a great tablet experience
that works in both
orientations.
So we spoke to the developer
of Pattrn, Lucas, earlier.
And we asked him to tell us a
little bit more about his
experience building a
Pure Android app.
LUCAS ROCHA: Hello.
I'm Lucas Rocha.
I'm the creator of Pattrn.
It's a unique app, like a
wallpaper app, for Android
phones and tablets.
What's unique about it is that
instead of the usual
photo-based wallpapers that you
get from other apps, it
gives you access to more than
200,000 patterns created by
the COLOURlovers community.
And the cool thing about working
with patterns in the
context of wallpapers is that
because they are tiled they
will always look great on any
form factor, because they
don't stretch or crop
or anything.
So it always works great.
That's the cool thing, and I
think that's one of the things
that is attracting a lot of
attention to the app now.
If I'm not mistaken, Pattrn was
one of the first apps to
implement proper design
for Nexus 7.
And I think maybe that was one
of the things that caught the
attention of the Google folks.
So that was an interesting
thing.
And actually, I started working
on the Tablet UI
because of the Nexus 7.
It's a great device.
I love it.
I have one.
And as part of the process, I
also implemented the 10 inch
UI, of course.
So it just made sense.
So responsive design is probably
one of the most
challenging things I had
to do on Pattrn.
Although Pattrn is in kind of a
privileged position in terms
of scalability just because the
content is so flexible in
terms of stretching, like
filling areas, because we are
tiling all the time.
So you don't have a lot of the
constraints in terms of the
content you're presenting.
So that helped a lot.
I had a lot of freedom to size
things properly without caring
about looking bad in some form
factors for example.
So there was one suggestion by
Roman Nurik which was to use
grid on landscape on phones.
And that's something I didn't
do just because I
didn't have time to.
But I definitely
want to do it.
It's just one of those details
that make a lot of difference
and I just didn't have
time to do it yet.
But I do get a lot of
inspirations from other apps.
This is one of the reasons
I watch the show.
Not live, most of the time.
But I always try to watch them
just because especially the
design in action stuff.
Especially that series
of proposed
designs from the community.
That was really inspiring.
And I think the big message,
from that amount of designs--
great designs that we got was
that there is clearly a design
language arising in the Android
platform, and that
helps, especially for developers
getting started in
the platform.
They have a reference, a visual
design to get started
and that helps a lot.
Especially if you don't have a
designer working with you.
So that helps a lot.
I'm not a designer.
I tend to see myself as
a developer with a
design eye to things.
So having this design language
helps a lot.
The think is, with any platform,
definitely just
going through API Docs
doesn't help at all.
So having some discussion, and
some reference designs, or
even reference implementations
of certain aspects of the
platform help a lot.
So this is where I think the
design action shows help a
lot, in terms of discussing one
topic and maybe talking
about existing reference
implementations.
And that helps a lot.
Implementation wise, to be
honest, it wasn't that
challenging.
I think the big thing with
Pattrn was finding the right
design for it.
And I usually spend much more
time thinking about how things
should look than implementing.
One thing I did for Pattrn that
helped a lot was I did
fragment-based implementation
from day one.
So I didn't have to
reimplement the
app to support tablets.
So I started with a phony UI,
pretty much with one fragment
inside one activity.
So a one-to-one relationship
for every bit of the UI.
So when I came to start working
on the tablet UI, it
was a natural thing to just put
two pieces together in a
different layout.
So that helped a lot.
I sketch a lot.
I have a very thick notebook,
and I have several
versions of the UI.
And I only start implementing
when I feel good about it.
It doesn't need to be perfect.
But I need to feel good about
the direction of things.
And that helps in terms of
avoiding reimplementing stuff,
just because you change your
mind while doing something.
And of course, as any software
development, you'll
learn as you do.
There's nothing in software
development that is
deterministic, like you know
what you're doing and you go
until you end with
the same idea.
So as you do it, you change
direction, you tweak something.
So actually there's something
interesting about
the design of Pattrn.
I started Pattrn, I wanted to
do something like a flick
board thing of wallpapers.
So it would look like
a magazine thing.
And in the end, I just couldn't
find a way to make it
look not right and nice.
So that was about the time
the whole Holo thing
started to pop up.
So once I got the design
language of Holo, the ICS
stuff, it just felt natural to
implement something that was
more in line of Androids.
Because flipboard is very--
I mean, it's a nice design,
but it's alien.
It's not really Android
in many ways.
It has some bits of Android
there, but not really.
So right now I'm working
on two things.
One is editing features.
So allowing you to change colors
of existing patterns,
adding brightness
and saturation,
this kind of thing.
A lot of people ask that.
They like the pattern, but they
don't like the colors,
this kind of thing.
And the other thing is syncing
across devices.
So you have favorites, your
wallpaper history.
You want that across all your
different Android devices.
And that's something
I'm working on now.
IAN NI-LEWIS: --to you today
is Tasks, by Team Tasks.
RETO MEIER: The Tasks Team have
also created a strong and
consistent brand style.
And I'm particularly impressed
by their icon, which is both a
distinctive silhouette and also
offers a really excellent
indication of what
the app offers.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Like Pattrn, the
learning curve to get started
with Task is virtually
nonexistent.
They've used a standard action
bar with icons and make it
immediately obvious how to add
new items to your list.
The view page is a simple
and obvious way to
switch between lists.
We love it.
And we also love small touches
that help make this app
particularly intuitive, like the
ability to drag and drop
items in the list
to reorder them.
They've also included some
excellent interactive widgets
which use the same
design language.
And we love us some widgets.
The tablet layout is exactly
what you'd expect.
Similarly intuitive, standard
multi-pane approach with a
fragment on the left and a
fragment on the right which
basically just removes a level
of navigation by letting you
modify your tasks while the
list is still visible.
Notice also, on this version,
they've implemented a
contextual action bar which
is very tablet-y.
So really well done there.
Now we also spoke to Jorim from
Task Team to find out a
little more about how he created
this Pure Android
experience.
RETO MEIER: Let's
listen to him.
JORIM JAGGI: Hi, my
name is Jorim.
I'm one of the developers
of the app
Tasks, from Team Tasks.
The app is basically designed
to sync with Google Tasks.
It's a relatively simple app,
where you can add your
personal tasks and show them in
Gmail and check them off.
The app is now like nine
months on Google Play.
It was released in April.
We had huge success with
engagement and ratings and,
yeah, it's a pretty cool app.
Based on the feedback of Google
Developer Advocates, we
implemented that you can set
customer reminder times for
every task.
But this is not synced
with Google Tasks
because it's not possible.
And also we did some minor clean
up, like, the Up button
on the Home screen was
pressable, but it didn't have
any action.
So we cleaned some stuff
like that up.
Like the change we did for the
reminder times helped ratings
and comments a lot.
It was like the number one
complaint about the app, that
people can't set custom reminder
times, and I can
understand why.
Although, it's kind of hard
for us because we really
designed the app to be
like the Google Tasks
client you can use.
And as soon as we implement
functionality, which we can't
sync, we have kind
of a problem.
So this is kind of a trade off
between a useful feature and
not being able to sync that.
But it helped a lot for our
ratings and comments.
So the most challenging parts
really the sync part.
It sounds pretty simple to sync
all your tasks with the
Google back end.
Sounds really simple, but it
gets really complicated
because it can have nests
of self tasks.
And then, what happens if you
delete the parent what happens
if the child, and
all this stuff.
And what we did there is kind
of we unit tested the whole
thing so that we were
sure that the
sync is working properly.
Because the sync code is kind
of the heart of the
application.
It's kind of the most important
stuff that the sync
always works.
And, yeah, that was kind of
really challenging, but it
worked out.
And we had almost no bugs.
We had some, a few bugs there,
but we figured it out.
Our app adapts itself to
the different device
configurations.
We basically design the app to
be compatible with four--
no, the three main buckets.
The size of a Nexus 4, the size
of a Nexus 7, and the
size of Nexus 10.
On a Nexus 4, you just
see the task list.
And then if you press your
task, you can edit it.
And on a Nexus 7, it's
kind of the same.
But if you rotated into
landscape, you see your tasks
on the left and the task
detail on the right.
So you can edit the task while
doing other tasks.
And on the Nexus 10 it's still
the same, but with more
spacing and bigger font sizes
and all this stuff.
But really designed to work
from the ground up.
We were clear this app has to
work with all kind of devices.
And Android makes it really
easy, I have to say.
They have a really powerful
resource system.
Select the correct resources
helped design apps that better
work with all screen sizes.
So our design process like
[INAUDIBLE], we do some sketches.
But then start implementing them
right away, because we
are more developers.
And it's really easy with the
tool in Eclipse now to do the
[INAUDIBLE] like writing code
and reuse it when you are
really want to implement
it to the whole design.
And we go normally from sketches
to implementation
right away.
And then iterate, of course,
with designers.
So my favorite part about
developing on the Android is
that you can design one app
and it runs on like 1,000
different devices.
That's really great.
And also Android provides a lot
of useful tools to achieve
that, to have a response
to design on
every of these devices.
So for example, the density
independent stuff.
It just runs everywhere and
also the whole thing with
fragments and the resource
system that you can have
fragments for this device, but
not on this screen size.
And that's really, really
pleasing that now I developed,
basically, for testing we used
these three devices.
A four inch phone, seven inch
tablet and a ten inch tablet,
then also a legacy device with
Android 2.2 for backwards
compatibility.
But then after that we didn't
have a single issue that it
didn't run on a device.
That was really great.
That you have like four devices
to test and it runs
everywhere.
So our next steps for the app
is kind of to integrate the
emails into the tasks.
There is a feature in Gmail
where you can add an email to
your task list.
And we just don't show
it on the device.
So we really would like to sync
all these email stuff
into the device and as soon as
you click on the link, you can
see the email in the mobile
web browser and stuff.
Besides that, we are also
looking with integrating our
data with third party widgets
like simple widgets, whatever.
There are lots of them and
they're all asking for a
content provider that
we provide.
So the users can show their
tasks on the custom.
They're really customized
widgets.
Yeah.
That's kind of what you're
looking for to build.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So congratulations
to Pattrn and
Tasks for making it
into Pure Android.
RETO MEIER: For the rest of you,
here's your opportunity
to find out how you, too, can
join these illustrious ranks.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Let's start
with the basics.
RETO MEIER: So yes.
There's sort of four key
things that you need to
consider to even be
in the running for
us to consider you.
And those are great assets,
having a great quality app,
having a great quality tablet
app, and following the Android
design guidelines.
Let's look at each of these in
a little bit more detail.
IAN NI-LEWIS: These really
are pretty basic.
I mean, for the assets, we're
looking for something that's
going to help us help you
sell your application.
The people that work for Google
Play really want to
help you sell your app.
But they can't do that if your
assets look like garbage.
RETO MEIER: Or if they're
not even there.
All right?
So we can't-- we will probably
not even look at your app on
the clinic if you don't at
least have your feature
graphic, basically all of the
assets which you need to
specify in Google Play done.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So, I think back
here we've actually got your
app, right, Reto?
RETO MEIER: We do.
This is my app.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Your
illustrious app.
RETO MEIER: I would like to
take some credit for the
assets here.
I can't take any.
Actually--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Was it
your doctor friend?
RETO MEIER: It was actually
not my doctor friend.
In this instance it was Roman
who actually put together
these quite impressive looking
graphics for me.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So what's the
one in the middle on the
bottom right here?
RETO MEIER: That is, that's
an earthquake.
IAN NI-LEWIS: But is that
the feature graphic?
RETO MEIER: That's the feature
graphic, yeah.
IAN NI-LEWIS: OK.
Because the contrast's
a little weird.
RETO MEIER: The contrast
is a little off, yeah.
IAN NI-LEWIS: We should probably
fix that if we're
going to feature you.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It's a really
good point though.
You need to have a feature
graphic in order for us to
feature you.
Because that's the graphic that
actually gets put on the
market, or on the Google Play
store, or in the collection.
And we can't automatically use
any of these other graphics.
That graphic has to be there.
RETO MEIER: And also take note
of things like, you'll note
that all of the apps that we
featured today all had both
phone screenshots and
tablet screenshots.
And another thing that you
should also consider is
including a promotional video.
And you can see that there is
a link for one here online.
Basically you want to do
everything you can to help the
Google Play team merchandise
your app.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
The promo video a lot of people
forget, but it's an
absolute no-brainer.
It's absolutely the most
effective way that we've found
to sell people on your app.
RETO MEIER: Once you've moved
beyond that, what we really
want you to look at is the
app quality guidelines.
Now this is something that you
can find on developer.android.
com on the Distribute
tab under Google
Play Quality Core.
And these are really sort of
the fundamental things.
So again, when we have people
internally looking at what
apps can we feature, what things
can we put into pure
Android, this is basically a
checklist of things which
we're going to look at as sort
of your bare minimum entry
requirements for what
we consider that to
be a quality app.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Now a lot of
people don't know the story
behind these, but Reto and I
actually spent months working
on these pages on convincing
the team to post those
guidelines.
Because originally, we just
had a set of internal QA
guidelines that we would run
any candidate for featuring
past, and if they failed those
guidelines they'd have to
either fix it or not
get featured.
And it took a long time to get
everyone involved to agree to
post these guidelines online,
but they finally
are there for you.
They really are the guidelines
that our QA team uses to
figure out whether an app
is featureable or not.
So if you're not meeting these
guidelines, you are not
meeting the lowest bar.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
So this is something you should
spend a lot of time
looking over and basically
as part of
own release QA checklist.
This is what we recommend you
do, is go through this, make
sure that you're meeting all
of these requirements.
And then you'll know that you
have an app that is quality,
it meets those quality
guidelines.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Of course,
just having an
app isn't good enough.
We also want that app to look
great on different devices.
And this year, we are
all about tablets.
So it's got to look
great on tablets.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
And you can find the tablet app
quality checklist also on
Google Play.
It's quality/tablet.
And so you'll find here a bunch
of best practices which
we look at to say, well, is this
a tablet app, is this not
a tablet app.
This is basically what we're
going to look at and what we
recommend you look at to say,
well, this meets that bar.
This is something which we think
tablet users are going
to be able to use and enjoy
on their devices.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And finally, we've
got the Android design
guidelines.
RETO MEIER: Ah, an
oldy but a goody.
So this is something which we
also launched last year.
Really exciting at
developer.android.com/design.
This tells you how to make an
app which looks like an
Android app.
Now there is a huge amount
of variation.
We don't want every app to look
the same, some sort of
cookie-cutter mold.
That's kind of boring.
But there are certain principles
which you can
conform to which are going to
make sure that every Android
user feels comfortable once
they get into the app.
And this is something which the
Android Design in Action
guys spend a lot of time
talking about on
their Tuesday show.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
This is when the way we got
these is by hiring an
excellent design team and
letting them run loose for a
while until they figured out
exactly what the design
language of Ice Cream Sandwich
was going to be.
And even though we expect that
to evolve, we don't expect
that to ever completely change
the way it did in Ice Cream
Sandwich again.
This is, for the foreseeable
future, what Android apps
should look like unless you have
a really good reason to
not make them look that way.
RETO MEIER: So once you've
sort of gone through and
created all of these basic
requirements for building an
app, which we're going to be
really excited about and are
going to be willing to feature
on our own collection--
in a collection we're going
to put our names against.
There's a few--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Actually, I think
just your name's on it.
RETO MEIER: Right now
it's just my name.
I don't think you're quite
that comfortable yet.
But nonetheless.
The next thing we're looking for
is something which makes
an even Pure-r-er Android than
just those basic criteria.
And these are things which
are kind of ephemeral.
This isn't stuff that you can
easily define in a checklist.
We want something that's really
efficient, that's
buttery smooth, it gives you
this sort of magical
experience when you're
using the app.
You kind of launch and you're
like, oh this is kind of cool.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It just
totally works.
Yeah, it feels right.
Exactly.
And efficient, I think we're
talking about, how easy is it
to get tasks done in the app?
Buttery, on the other hand, I
think we're really referring
to the efficiency
of your code.
And that one actually,
personally, I can measure.
If your code is running
consistently at 30 to 60 FPS
on a newer device, then
it's not buttery.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
And we're also looking at
efficiency and butteriness in
terms of things like
your battery life.
You don't want to have the user
being conscious of the
fact that your app is doing
anything other than running
without draining your
battery at all.
I think a good example of that
delightful aspect is something
like Pattrn, which creates
attractive wallpapers or
allows you to browse attractive
wallpapers.
Now, I don't really change the
wallpapers on my app, but I
found myself when looking at
this app, just sort of
flicking through and just having
fun with something
which isn't necessarily
something I normally would.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Whereas Tasks
delighted me, even though it
is the simplest app possible,
they just didn't
get anything wrong.
All I wanted was a task list.
I didn't need a skeuomorphic
design, I didn't need bells
and whistles, I just needed
the task list that worked
exactly the way I expected
it to work.
And everything that they added,
whether it's the list
drag and drop or whatever, was
something that added to my
sense of the app responding
the way I expected it to.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
So I think that pretty much
wraps it up for us today.
So tune in to Roman, Nick, and
Adam for Android Design in
Action on Tuesday.
They're going to be
doing a design
exploration on a soccer--
or football, depending on what
country you're in-- app.
And they're going to be
doing a deep dive on
launcher icons as well.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And we're going
to follow their lead.
So next Friday we'll
be looking at
sport stream tracking.
And if you've got a device
profile app you'd like to take
a look at be sure
to let us know.
RETO MEIER: Put everything
you want them
into the Trello page.
This is where we're going to be
collecting nominations for
the apps that we're going to
look at and sort of listing
the categories which are
under consideration.
So this is where you self
nominate to possibly be part
of the Pure Android
collection.
So we're going to start digging
through the archives
of the App Clinic app reviews
over the last year or so to
try and find more Pure
Android candidates.
We already have a short list
of apps which we're pretty
excited about, which we're going
to start rolling out.
But if you've made some changes
to your app recently
or since we reviewed it, and
you'd like us to take another
look and put it into
consideration, do let us know
on Google+ and we will
add it to our queue.
And hopefully it'll
make the cut.
So until then, I'm Reto Meier.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And I'm
Ian Ni-Lewis.
RETO MEIER: And this has
been the App Clinic.